hemos hablado bastante de la demanda y
del excedente del consumidor ya ha
llegado la hora de ver el otro lado de
la moneda pensemos en la curva pero esta
vez en la curva de la oferta la curva de
la oferta y ya estas alturas seguramente
te imaginarás que existe algo llamado el
excedente del productor así que digamos
que este es el eje del precio este va a
ser la cantidad y ya que andamos
suponiendo vamos a decir que tenemos una
granja de fresas y esta va a ser la
curva de la oferta y también dibujemos
la curva de la demanda justo aquí y
ahora que ya tenemos este par de curvas
también podemos pensar en el precio por
ejemplo podemos pensar acerca de qué
tanta cantidad tendremos la oferta así
que pensemos que hay una cierta cantidad
dada con la cual nosotros tenemos un
cierto precio y este a su vez tiene que
estar en orden con todo lo que produce
el producto ahora bien pensando en la
cantidad que tenemos de fresas vamos a
darla en miles de kilogramos de fresas y
tenemos mil kilogramos de fresas 2000
kilogramos de fresas 3000 4000 5000
por el precio vamos a darlo en peso por
kilogramo tenemos un peso por kilogramo
dos pesos por kilogramo tres pesos por
kilogramo cuatro aquí ya se ve medio feo
mejor dos pesos por kilogramo
aquí está tres pesos por kilogramo
cuatro pesos por kilogramo y cinco pesos
por kilogramo así que para empezar este
análisis vamos a decir que lo que
queremos es que la oferta de lo que
vamos a producir sea mil kilogramos de
fresas para empezar entonces queremos
producir mil kilogramos de fresas y la
pregunta puede ser la siguiente cual
tendría que ser el precio para ellos
para poder producir mil kilogramos de
fresas bueno si lo pensamos desde la
perspectiva del proveedor o desde la
perspectiva de la oferta o desde el
punto de vista del granjero de estas
fresas si lo que se quiere es producir
mil kilogramos de fresas entonces aquí
en la curva de la oferta dice que lo
mínimo que se tiene que pagar son un
peso por kilogramo de cada una de estas
fresa porque si no se paga de mínimo
esta cantidad si se paga menos que esta
cantidad entonces pues de granjero sale
perdiendo y entonces el granjero va a
dejar de ser
fresas para sembrar manzanas kiwis o
tendrá que vender sus tierras o se irá a
la ciudad o va a tener que rentar sus
tierras para ganado qué sé yo pero si lo
que queremos es que el granjeros sigan
produciendo fresas entonces lo que hay
que pagarles mínimo la cantidad que dice
en la curva de oferta así que tendremos
que pagar el precio que dice en la curva
de oferta de mínimo
si estamos interesados en que se sigan
produciendo fresas sentida que pagar esa
cantidad y ojo estamos dando un promedio
justo cuando dibujo este rectángulo pues
si el productor quisiera vender 500
kilogramos de fresas el costo sería
distinto si quisiera vender 800 49
kilogramos de fresas también por lo
tanto estamos eligiendo el promedio de
estos precios y es justo este bueno
ahora pensemos que el granjero quiere
producir otros 1000 kilogramos de fresas
así que veamos el caso en el que el
granjero quiere producir un total de
2.000 kilogramos de presas en que
tenemos ahora a criticarnos pues
exactamente es lo mismo para producir
1000 kilogramos más lo que vamos a
suponer es que se está usando los
recursos lo mejor posible y es que en
cierta forma esta misma cantidad de
dinero
en la curva de oferta es decir la mínima
cantidad de dinero que nos pide el
granjero nos hace suponer que el
granjero la va a utilizar para sacar el
mayor provecho a la producción de estas
fresas esto de aquí es suponer que se
está usando los recursos lo más
adecuadamente recursos más adecuados es
decir el granjero realmente sabe cómo
hacer crecer las fresas sabe cómo
aprovechar el espacio en sus tierras de
esta manera sus fresas crecen en el
óptimo también tal vez sepa cómo
transportar mejor o sepa cómo moverlas
de tal manera que sea más barato que
venderlas en su granja etcétera y ojo
estamos hablando por año si lo que
queremos son otros mil kilogramos de
fresas entonces ellos tendrán que subir
el precio en la curva de oferta pues tal
vez la transportación sea más cara o es
necesario más personal o más agua o la
granja es más grande o habrán nuevas
labores que hacer para seguir dando
recursos que sean adecuados lo que sea
es por eso que el costo de oportunidad
para los siguientes mil kilogramos de
fresas es un poco mayor así que el costo
será un poco mayor esto
va a ser un poco mayor el promedio de
los costos o de los precios serán
mayores y es por eso que dibujo este
rectángulo fijándome en el promedio
recuerden que es el promedio pues si
quisiéramos el costo de una cierta
cantidad de kilogramos tendremos que
fijarnos en su valor en la curva el
costo para 1000 y 1 kilogramos está
justo aquí en curso para 2.000
kilogramos está justo aquí y para esto
hago este rectángulo ahora la misma
situación para los siguientes mil
kilogramos si lo que queremos es una
oferta de 3.000 kilogramos entonces
tendrá un precio mayor y por lo tanto el
costo de oportunidad
aumenta así que de esta manera la curva
de oferta y ojo no es más larga cuando
decíamos cuál es la cantidad que
deberíamos de vender si fijamos el
precio tres pesos o claro son tres mil
kilogramos no no ahora lo que estamos
diciendo es si nosotros queremos que los
proveedores produzcan 3.000 kilogramos
entonces cuál tendrá que ser el precio
en ese momento ahora visto de esta
manera podemos entender a la curva de
oferta como una curva de oportunidad de
costo esto hablando de los productores y
si decimos que esta es la oferta y la
demanda y si tomamos ahora el punto en
donde se cortan es decir nos fijamos
en el precio de cuatro pesos por
kilogramo y fijamos este precio en donde
la oferta es la misma que la demanda
este va a ser el precio de mercado ahora
bien qué va a pasar por arriba de este
precio pues todos los proveedores y para
hacerlo más sencillo vamos a suponer que
en efecto son cuatro pesos y que la
cantidad de demanda y de ofertas de
4.000 kilogramos esto pasa a ser lo más
sencillo que va a pasar aquí bueno los
primeros 4.000 kilogramos de fresas
producidos por la granja tienen un costo
de oportunidad para ellos de cuatro
pesos por kilogramo para que se
produzcan y seríamos justo en el límite
pero por los primeros tres mil
novecientos noventa y nueve kilogramos
el costo de oportunidad para producirlos
es menor que el precio que tenemos para
producción así que en este caso el
granjero está obteniendo más por los
nuevos tres mil novecientos noventa y
nueve kilogramos y con ello está
obteniendo más por sus presas que su
costo de oportunidad y ya con esto
tenemos la idea del excedente del
productor así que por ejemplo por estos
primeros mil kilogramos de fresas que
tenemos justo aquí los proveedores
tienen un costo de oportunidad un poco
menor a un peso por kilogramo pero ellos
obtendrán cuatro pesos por cada
kilogramo por los siguientes mil kilos
y el costo de oportunidad es
aproximadamente 2 pesos por kilogramo no
sé cómo 1.75 a ojo de buen cubero y de
nuevo cómo se vende a 4 pesos entonces
da un excedente del productor cercano a
2 pesos y al ahora bien si pensamos en
el mercado por completo se tienen que
toda esta área que voy a colorear toda
esta área es el excedente del productor
es decir el exceso en el valor que ellos
obtienen por arriba y más allá del costo
de oportunidad y es justo esta área a lo
que le llamamos el excedente del
productor ahora bien si asumimos que la
curva de oferta es una recta como en
este caso entonces simplemente tenemos
que sacar el área de un triángulo cuya
altura es de 4 a 1 que son 3 y cuya base
son de 1 a 4 mil recuerden que son miles
de kilogramos por lo tanto son 4000
kilogramos y bueno ya con esto tenemos
el excedente del consumidor que es el
área este triángulo el excedente del
consumidor que es igual a la altura que
vale 3 por la base esperen primero lo
voy a poner de otro color para que no
nos confundamos entonces la altura que
vale 3 por la base quedan 4
y todo esto hay que dividirla entre dos
o multiplicarlo por un medio es como si
sacáramos la mitad de este rectángulo
por lo tanto nos va a quedar 3 por 400 y
todo esto multiplicado por un medio y
esto es igual a bueno un medio por tres
son tres medios por cuatro mil es lo
mismo que cuatro mil entre dos por tres
que son seis mil y si ahora nos fijamos
en las unidades el precio está dado en
pesos por kilogramo la cantidad de esta
edad en kilogramos y por lo tanto nos
quedan simplemente pesos es decir seis
mil pesos del excedente del productor
por semana